Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Ja, ich habe mich schon gesagt, bitte schön.
Ja, so erst wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Helmut Braun.
Helmut Braun, ja.
Ich möchte Ihre Nachname stabilieren, um sicher so gehen.
Ja.
Wie Bertha, Elbi, Richard, Avi, Anton, Uwe, Ulrich, Envy, Nordpol, ja.
Richtig, genau.
Okay.
Herr Braun, wie alt sind Sie denn?
Ich bin 52 Jahre alt.
Gut.
Dann sind Sie ganz genau geboren?
5. Juli 1971.
Wie viel wiegen Sie so Zeit?
Oh, ungefähr 75 Kilo, glaube ich.
Ich habe jetzt nicht gewogen längere Zeit.
Okay.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,85 m, war ich mal.
Ja, danke schön für die Information.
Gerne.
Ja, Herr Braun, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Hallo, Herr Drich, komm zu Ihnen, weil ich, ja, es ist vielleicht
eine längere Geschichte, aber der Grund ist, dass ich jetzt seit ein paar
Tagen Übelkeit hatte und dann jetzt auch heute erbrochen haben.
Das war so Braun gewesen.
Muss aber dazu sagen, dass ich seit einigen Wochen schon so
ja, Magenschmerzen, Bauchbeschwerden, wie auch immer man das sagen,
mal beschreiben, mal Hab oder hatte und fühle mich jetzt auch schwach
insgesamt und ja, das war der Grund, warum ich jetzt zu Ihnen
kommen bin, weil das war auffällig dieses, was ich erbrochen habe.
Das kenne ich so nicht.
Okay.
Also ich nehme an, das ist für Sie neu her.
Ja, das habe ich vorher nie gehabt.
Okay.
Herr Braun, also, wie fühlen Sie sich jetzt, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie sich etwas erschöpfen können?
Also ich fühle mich schwach.
Also sind Sie schwinder?
Kann ich jetzt so nicht sagen, nein, ich finde es nicht,
aber also ich fühle mich irgendwie körperlich schwach.
Okay.
Was haben Sie erbrochen?
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass Blut drin ist?
Es war kein Blut, Doktor, nee, aber es war so Braun bis so
dunkel Braun, vielleicht schwarz sogar, ich weiß nicht.
Also das war, habe ich früher nie gehabt, ich habe früher mal
erbrochen, aber das war nie so wie jetzt.
Sie haben nur einmal erbrochen, ne?
Deswegen bin ich dann gleich jetzt kranker aus zu Ihnen gekommen.
Also Magenschmerzen, wie würden Sie Ihre Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie schwinder?
Ja, sind eher so dumpfe, also Schmerzen ist ein bisschen übertrieben,
ich kenne die Schmerzen ja von meinem Knie und so weiter.
Also so irgendwie ein Druckgefühl, also ein unangenehmes Gefühl
im Oberbauch, würde ich mal sagen.
Schmerzen würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen.
Also sind die Beschwerden plötzlich auch getreten?
Nee, sind so ein, zwei Wochen ungefähr, ja.
Also Herr Braun, wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala
von null Besten?
Also wie gesagt, es ist keine Schmerzen, kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Also seit haben Sie keine Schmerzen.
Ich habe andere Schmerzen, Knie habe ich Schmerzen, ja.
Ist Ihnen aufgefallen, gibt es etwas, diese Schmerzen
lindert oder verstärkt?
Also ich habe mir mal so einen Kirchkernkissen genommen,
aber das hat nicht viel geholfen von dich.
Was haben Sie genommen?
Ein Kirchkernkissen, als Wärme, Wärmekissen.
Kennen Sie das nicht, Herr Doktor, Kirchkernkissen?
Ja, also ich denke, das ist eine warme Wasserkissen oder so was, ja.
Aber nicht Wasser, das ist ein Kirchkerne, die tut man in die Mikrowelle.
Also so ein Beutel aus Stoff, den kann man auch wärmen,
meistens in der Mikrowelle, dann ist es warmer, kann man hier drauf tun.
Kirchkerne sind das, also wenn die Kirchen ist und die Kerne sammelt,
kann man das selbst mal an, sogar.
Ja, okay.
Kann ich empfehlen?
Ja, vielleicht.
Ich brauche, grob ich das.
Haben Sie bemerkt, gibt das Auslöse, diese Magenschmerzen
oder seit wann haben Sie Magenschmerzen,
früher haben Sie auch ähnliche Magengruppe Schmerzen, ja.
Ja, hatte ich ja, aber es gibt da keinen Auslöse,
also es ist so ein dumpfes Gefühl im Oberbau.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen?
Ein bisschen noch nicht, ne.
Was ich mir denken kann, also ich habe in den letzten ein,
zwei Wochen ein bisschen viel gefeiert und da war auch ein bisschen
mehr Alkohol dabei und ich weiß nicht, ob es vielleicht damit
zusammenhängt, könnte sein, das ist meine Vermutung.
Wann war das?
Also vorletztes Wochenende, in diesem Wochenende auch,
da waren wir mit Freunden unterwegs und haben dann
ein bisschen gefeiert.
Letzte Wochen haben Sie gesehen?
Beide, diese letzten Wochenende ja.
Ja Herr Braun, fühlen Sie sich fibrig oder haben Sie Feber,
haben Sie gemessen?
Hab ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber ich fühle mich nicht heiß an, nein.
Okay, haben Sie Schlafstörungen oder so?
Nach der Schweiz.
Nach der Schweiz habe ich nicht Schlafstörungen, also ich gehe,
also zweimal nachts muss ich auf Toilette raus,
gehe nach dem, wie viel ich trinke am Abend vorher,
sonst habe ich keine Schlafstörungen.
Okay, aber gut, Sie haben geregt, dass Sie Öbelkeit
unterbrechen gehabt, haben Sie auch Durchfall oder Verstopfung?
Nein, hatte ich bisher nicht gehabt, nein, nein.
Also beim Messerlassen, haben Sie Probleme beim Messerlassen?
Nein, ich nicht, nein.
Ist Ihnen noch gefallen, in der Last-Aside-Up oder so genommen,
und wie viele Veränderungen haben Sie?
Nein, also, ist mir nicht darauf gefahren, habe ich jetzt nicht gemerkt,
nein, ungefähr gleich seit Jahren.
Haben Sie Burschschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen oder Atemnoten?
Also ich habe jetzt keine Kopfschmerzen,
ein Datennot habe ich jetzt gemerkt, also ich fühle mich
insgesamt sehr schwach, habe ich gesagt,
und wenn ich jetzt so ein bisschen schneller laufe
oder treppen strege, dann bin ich schon etwas aus der Puste,
finde ich, ja, also das ist, das Fitness hat nachgelassen.
Leiden Sie unter Sort-Rennen?
Nein, ich habe jetzt nicht so gehabt, eigentlich nein.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass etwas Blasen ist?
Was meinen Sie?
Blasen, so.
Blasen? Ich habe keine Blasen, nein.
Meinen Sie Hauptblasen oder was meinen Sie?
Ja, Hauptblasen, meine ich.
Nein.
Warum fragen Sie, Herr Doktor, ist das etwas,
das damit zu tun, mit den Bläsern?
Bläsern, ja, das ist eine Hautveränderung.
Bläschen, ah, okay, Bläschen.
Ja, habe ich nicht.
Blutarmung, Patienten hat es sonst,
sei es mir nicht.
Okay, nein, das habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Okay.
Herr Braun, leiden Sie unter irgendwelche chronischen
Krankheiten oder wichtige Krankheiten,
das ich wissen sollte?
Also ich habe eine Knieartrose,
das kommt, ich hatte mal vor vielen Jahren
einen Unfall gehabt und das sind die Folgen.
Welche?
Rechtes Knie.
Und da nehme ich auch, also das hat auch ein bisschen
zugenommen, diese Artrose, der Orthopäde,
bei dem ich war, hat gesagt, man muss sicherlich
irgendwann mal auch an eine Operation denken.
Das war erst mal mit Schmerzmedikamenten,
das probieren, ich habe jetzt in den letzten
Wochen auch wegen Kriegschmerzen auch viel
Schmerzmedikamente eingenommen,
das haben Sie genommen?
Ich habe auch einen Diplofenak genommen,
Ibuprofen.
Wie sind deine Ansichtdosis?
Also ich habe da mehrere Tabletten manchmal am
Tag genommen.
Also Diplofenak, wie viele Milliarden
haben Sie?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Okay, kann ich nicht sagen.
Leiden Sie unter noch andere chronischen Krankheiten?
Ja, also ich nehme auch Tabletten gegen Bluthochdruck,
die sind viel an festgestellt worden.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette ein.
Kann der Satan?
Okay.
Wie ist der Dosis?
16 Milligramm morgens.
Und noch was?
Dann habe ich noch ein Medikament,
ich hatte letztes Jahr eine Trombose gehabt.
Also das war letztes Jahr,
November, also das ist jetzt so ungefähr
vier Monate her, da war die Trombose
an einer Flugreise, ich hatte eine Flugreise gehabt,
dann habe ich dann ein dickes Bein gehabt,
dann ist die Trombose festgestellt worden.
Das ist nämlich ein Blutverdünnungs-Ein,
also Elequiser ist das Medikament.
5 Milligramm, ja, 1 am morgens und abends.
Wirklich einmal, ne?
2 Mal morgens und abends eine Tablette.
Und noch was?
Das werden die daran nicht einnehmen.
Nehmen Sie auch
Magenschutz-Tablette?
Hab ich das nicht genommen.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Sie haben erwähnt, das Knipp-Problem?
Also ja, mindestkuss-Operation habe ich gehabt,
mit Erdroskopie.
Außer Erdroskopie?
Haben Sie noch?
Ne, sonst keine Operation.
Okay.
Erbrauen, haben Sie allegegegen etwas?
Oder Unverträglichkeit?
Nein, ist nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft gegen Corona?
Den Corona habe ich 3 Impfungen gehabt, ja.
Und Kindheit-Impfungen?
Haben Sie das auch durchgeführt?
Kindheit-Impfungen?
Das kann ich nicht so sagen,
dass ich mal mit passen kann.
Okay.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Ja, im November war ich im Ausland.
Da war ich in Thailand.
Okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt das.
Also Herr Braun, treiben Sie Sport regelmäßig?
Ne, unregelmäßig.
Was machen Sie unregelmäßig?
Also ich spiele ab und zu ein bisschen Tennis mit meinen Freunden.
Okay.
Aber nicht so viel, weil mein Knie manchmal ärger macht.
Okay, ich verstehe ja.
Herr Braun, ich möchte über Ihre Familien etwas wissen, ja.
Sind Ihre Eltern am Leben?
Ne, meine Eltern sind beide schon gestorben.
Das tut mir leid, mein Beileid.
Also, wie lernen Sie sich, woran hat sie gestorben?
Also mein Vater ist schon ziemlich früh gestorben,
Verkehrsunfall und mein Mutter hat einen Schlaganfall gehabt.
Meine meine, also haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin Einzelkind.
Okay, sind Sie verheiratet, Herr Braun?
Ich bin geschieden.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, ich habe keine Kinder.
Okay, leben Sie allein?
Ich lebe als Signal, ja.
Was machen Sie erst beruflich, Herr Braun?
Ja, ich bin selbstständig, ich habe so eine, ich verkaufe Autos.
Was machen Sie, Reparins-Auto?
Ich verkaufe Autos.
Verkaufe Autos, okay, ja.
Also ich nehme Ihren Job ein bisschen stressig, oder?
Geht so, normal.
Okay.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Braun?
Ja, ich rauche, ja.
Wie viel und seit wann rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich habe als Jugendliche angefangen,
dann habe ich mal zehn Jahre auch mal nicht geraucht,
dann habe ich diese angefangen,
also vielleicht ein halbes bis ein Päckchen pro Tag ungefähr.
Also das heißt, ungefähr seit 30 Jahren,
Sie haben geraucht und 10,
ja, 25 Jahre vielleicht, ja.
Okay.
Aber in den letzten zehn Jahren, Sie haben nie geraucht.
Ja, letztens habe ich geraucht, also ich habe wieder angefangen,
ich weiß es nicht, vor sechs, sieben Jahren habe ich wieder angefangen.
Okay.
Also Sie haben eine Pause gemacht, dann wieder?
Ja, habe ich wieder angefangen, leider, ja.
Herr Braun, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so gelegentlich, ja.
Wie nein, sehr gelegentlich?
Ja, so Bier zum Essen oder so,
oder am Wochenende, wenn ich feiere halt ein bisschen mehr,
habe ich nicht mehr gesagt, dass ich da ein bisschen viel Alkohol getragen habe.
Ja, dann schon.
Also aber Sie trinken nicht täglich, ja?
Ja, doch im Bier, Sie schon mal essen.
Wie viel?
Ja, ein, zwei Fleisch und vielleicht so pro Tag.
Okay.
Bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
das ist eine Routine-Frage, Herr Braun.
Haben Sie Kontakt damit, dann drogern?
Darauf möchte ich nicht antworten.
Okay.
Also ist das wichtig jetzt, oder warum fragen Sie?
Ja, natürlich, also Sie haben mal Geschmöchsen,
also auch Geschmöchsen, vielleicht, deswegen können auch,
die Hochschmöchsen auch getrieben werden.
Ich möchte nicht darauf antworten, ich weiß nicht, warum Sie das so wichtig finden.
Das ist für uns wichtig, natürlich.
Okay, darüber sprechen wir wieder, ja?
Ja, später vielleicht mal.
Okay.
Herr Braun, Sie haben gesagt,
dass Sie seit einigen Tagen Übelkeit,
und danach haben Sie einmal erbrochen,
Sie haben Magenschmerzen, ja?
Aber so seit Sie haben keine Magenschmerzen,
aber gestern...
Das ist vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel gesagt, ja?
Ja, okay.
Und Sie leiden unter auch Erschoffung, ja?
Ich fühle mich etwas schwächer.
Ja, richtig.
Und ein bisschen atemnot auch,
wir haben uns Sortbrinnen, ja?
Sortbrinnen habe ich nicht, Herr Doktor, nee?
Nein, ne?
Nein.
Wir haben keine Februar, ja?
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder fragen Sie mich?
Was meinst du, ist das...
Ich will jetzt nicht im Krankenhaus bleiben,
ich habe morgen wichtige Termine,
können wir das auch irgendwie ambulant behandeln,
weil ich kann auf keinen Fall bleiben heute Nacht im Krankenhaus.
Ja, ich kann.
Ich kann gerade sagen, dass Sie eine große Problem
oder kleine Probleme haben, das ist so früher, ja?
Ich muss so als Sie körperliche Untersuchung dann erst abnehmen.
Was machen, können Sie am heutem machen, alles, ja?
Ja, ich werde so erst alle machen,
danach eine Entscheidung betroffen, ja, alles.
Ja, aber ich kann auf keinen Fall bleiben,
ich habe einen sehr wichtigen Termin, also...
Ja, natürlich, ich möchte sehen,
aber Ihre Gesundheit noch wichtigst als Ihre Termin, ich denke.
Ja, aber wenn der Termin ausfällt, dann bringt man auch Gesundheit nicht,
da bin ich tot, da bin ich pleite, da bin ich bankrott.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, Sie sind nicht...
Dann bringt man das Leben nichts für mich,
dann kann ich gleich ins Grab gehen.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie an, also, aber...
Es könnte auch ganz, ganz wichtig sein,
Leben bedrohlich auch sein, also, wie gesagt, es ist so früher.
Ja, aber wenn Sie dann, wäre ich hier mal so vorhin sitzen,
wenn ich so lebensbedrohlich wäre.
Es ist so früher, so sagen, aber nach den Ergebnissen
kann ich noch wichtiger...
Gut, dann reden wir später nochmal,
wenn wir Ergebnisse haben, Herr Doktor, ja?
Ja, wir sprechen danach wieder darüber.
Vielen Dank für diese Gespräche.
Okay, danke, Herr Doktor.
Gut, gibt es Fragen aus dem Chat,
oder aus den Zuhörern, was noch gefragt werden sollte,
oder was Sie noch gefragt hätten?
Der Patient hat gesagt, keine Stuhlgangprobleme,
aber wir müssen detaillierte Fragen stellen.
Richtig, ja.
Ja.
Sieht Ihre Stuhlgang Konsistenz und Farbe,
wie Sie mir beschreiben.
Mhm, ich habe mir auch Notizen gemacht,
ja, der Stuhlgang ist schwarz gewesen, ja,
ganz dunkel, ja.
Das ist eine wichtige Frage, ja.
Der Herr Doktor hat zwar gefragt,
haben Sie durch oder Verstopfung,
aber hat dann gesagt, nee, aber manche
muss da manchmal ein bisschen nachbohren, ja,
sagen, okay, aber wie sieht er aus,
ist irgendwie auffälliger anders als sonst, ja.
Also er hat schwarzen Stuhl,
die haben mich schwarzen Stuhl seit einigen Tagen, ja.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, ja.
Weitere Kommentare oder Fragen?
Appetit, wir haben nicht gefragt.
Appetit ist aktuell wegen Übelkeit vermindert.
Aber als Akut, vorher war kein Problem.
Aber jetzt Akut wegen Übelkeit ist vermindert, ja.
Richtig, gut.
Was haben Sie noch gefragt?
Sie haben nach Bläschen gefragt,
Bläschen oder...
Er hat gesagt, bei der Bewegung
eine Puste...
Er hat nicht gesagt, Puste hat gesagt,
wenn er sich bewegt oder Treppenstacke,
hat er ein bisschen Probleme mit der Atmung
und mit der Puste hat er gesagt, Puste.
Was ist Puste?
Ich komme ausgedeht.
Also wenn man sagt, ich komme aus der Puste
oder aus der Puste, heißt es,
ich bin kurzatmig.
Aus der Puste kommen.
Erstmal, ich habe gehört.
Aus der Puste.
Umgangssprache, aus der Puste kommen.
Hat nichts mit Husten zu tun.
Puste heißt also Atmung.
Wenn Sie Sport machen,
gehe ich noch etwas zur Selbenzeit.
Sie haben gesagt, Atmung und dann nach,
zum Beispiel Herzrasen,
Schwindelik.
Schwindel hat er gefragt, es war nichts.
Und Herzrasen hat er jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Hat er nicht bemerkt zumindest mal.
Aber kann sein, ja.
Das ist Herzklopft oder der Pulsrast,
kann man fragen, ja.
Stoppen kann auch sein.
Wolfgang kann auch mal sagen, ja.
Wann sind Sie
letzte Mal als Besuch,
zum Beispiel für die Versorgung?
Also einige Monate her.
Zwei Monate vielleicht, ja.
Welche Dabur-Werte
oder bisgebenen Diagnostik
durchgeführt werden?
Er war beim Haus, hat es gewesen,
wegen seinem Knie
und wegen Rezept für Eliquis,
ein neues Rezept für Eliquis.
Hat er ein neues Rezept bekommen,
das war der Grund, warum er beim Arzt war.
Wie viel Monate
505 Milligramm?
So vier Monate ungefähr.
Ja, und noch,
Ihra Arz hat gesagt,
sechs Monate oder?
Hat sechs Monate gesagt, ja.
Noch eine Frage?
Sie sind noch abhängig,
wann haben Sie gelerscht,
wann haben Sie das gemacht?
Ja, er hat
keine Schmerzen, deswegen
konnte er auch keine Angabe
auf der Schmerzskala machen,
aber die sind jetzt
unabhängig gewesen.
Hat nicht gemerkt, dass es
nach dem Essen besser oder schlechter geworden ist.
Hat er nicht gemerkt.
Was machen Sie, wenn ein Patient sagt,
es ist keine Schmerzen, ich habe zwei Beschwerden.
Das ist ja so ein Wortspiel.
Er hat gesagt, ich habe Magenbeschwerden
und Magenschmerzen.
Was machen Sie mit so etwas?
Muss man da eine Schmerzskala angeben lassen?
Ja, Schmerzskala
müssen wir
fragen.
Er sagt, er kann keine Schmerzen,
weil er keine Schmerzmedikamente nimmt.
Aber wie viel
müssen wir fragen?
Ja,
es hat der Doktor auch richtig gemacht,
nach Schmerzen gefragt.
Er hat dann gesagt,
es sind keine Schmerzen, dann Beschwerden.
Dann kann man das sagen,
es sind Magenbeschwerden
oder Oberbauchbeschwerden.
Dann würde ich auch keine Schmerzskala
angeben, in dem Fall.
Ja,
das müssen wir fragen.
Reflex
hat gefragt,
nach Sodbrennen haben Sie gefragt.
Sodbrennen, also als
analog zum Reflex.
Hat er aber nicht berichtet,
hat es keine Beschwerden mit Reflex gehabt.
Schmerzen?
Ob die Schmerzen ausstrahlen,
kann er nicht sagen, weil er keine Schmerzen hat.
Es sind Beschwerden,
ja.
Im Englischen sagt man nicht
Pain, sondern Discomfort.
Also
unbehagen oder beschwerden.
Discomfort.
Im Englischen sagt man Discomfort.
Discomfort, ja.
Nicht Pain, sondern Discomfort.
Discomfort.
Ja.
Weil es jemand, FSB auf Englisch machen möchte,
irgendwann mal in Amerika.
Können wir anfangen, Arsatz,
ja.
Also ich glaube, die wichtigsten Fragen
sind gestellt worden.
Wie fanden Sie die Reaktion
zu der Aussage
vom Patienten,
dass er nach Hause gehen möchte unbedingt?
Ja.
Welche Reaktionen
haben wir?
Ich fand die Reaktion gut,
Arsatz sagt, ich kann jetzt noch nichts
genaues sagen.
Man muss abwarten,
dass es ein sehr verliegendes oder lebensbedrohliches sein kann.
Das ist richtig,
wie man es gesagt hat.
Wenn der Patient sagt,
ich gehe auf jeden Fall nach Hause
und kann der Arzt sagen,
wir können Sie jetzt beraten
und Empfehlungen geben,
aber entscheiden müssen Sie selbst.
Manchmal sagen Sie,
wenn die so kommen,
Sie wissen jetzt kein Gefängnis.
Wenn wir empfehlen,
dass Sie da bleiben,
kann man sagen.
Aber diese Lösung war auch gut,
dass er gesagt hat,
wir untersuchen erstmal, machen mal ein paar Tests
und dann können wir später noch mal sprechen darüber.
Das nimmt so ein bisschen die Spannung aus dem Gespräch.
Das ist manchmal hilfreich.
Man fand ich gut.
Der Patient hat nicht...
Ja,
der hat jetzt ein bisschen aggressiv reagiert,
glaube ich.
Ja, aggressiv reagiert.
Welche Reaktion?
Also, das ist ein Zeichen dafür,
dass er am ersten Brocken nimmt,
wird das so interpretieren als Arzt.
Und dann kann man das
nochmal, wie es gemacht wurde,
sagen, okay,
wir reden später noch mal darüber
oder wir klammern
dieses Thema aus.
Und wenn jetzt irgendwelche Befunde
kommen, wo das nochmal wichtig werden könnte,
werden wir nochmal darüber sprechen.
Der Patient hat gesagt,
Alkohol
konsum,
zia benik
gezerrte
gelegentlich,
denach,
bisin via file.
Welche Reaktion
in via...
Also, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht so
Werten, ich will nicht sagen, oh, das viel
oder oh, das wenig, sondern einfach sagen, okay,
ich nehme das zur Kenntnis
und ist neutral bleiben bei so was immer.
besser neutral bleiben, ja.
Und oft ist es so, dass
wir den Patienten sagen, das ist ja
subjektiv für ihn, das ist wenig halt,
weil andere trinken, viel Alkohol
ist jeden Tag ein Kasten Bier zu trinken, zum Beispiel.
Er trinkt nur wenig, zwei Flaschen pro Bier
pro Tag
und
das ist
ein Veranterlorn.
Ich würde immer nach Frage noch, ob
auch harte Sachen trinken, ja, also Bier ist
hier für die meisten, wie Orangenssaft, ja,
in Deutschland, ja, ist so wie Wasser,
Bier ist für die kein Alkohol
und dann macht es auch mal Sinn zu
fragen, trinken sie auch harte Sachen,
wie zum Beispiel Schnaps
oder
Schnaps bedeutet Whiskey.
Whiskey ist auch eine Art von Schnaps, genau,
ja, oder Whiskey kann man fragen, Schnaps oder Wodka,
das man so speziell fragt, weil das
sind die Hochprozentigen, ja,
die haben viel kurz Alkohol
gehalten, das kann man nochmal fragen,
ja, weil für manches
Leute sagen, Bier ist kein Alkohol für die,
ja, Schnaps oder
harte was.
Bitte?
Harte was oder starke Sachen
oder harte Sachen?
Kann man beides sagen,
kann man beides sagen,
kann man beides sagen, ja, ja,
hart oder auch
starke Sachen,
oder Sie fragen halt direkt nach, trinken Sie
halt auch Schnaps oder
Hochprozentige Sachen,
kann man direkt fragen auch, ja.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Ich komme mal zur Oberarztvorstellung, ja?
Ja.
Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt,
hatten Sie kurz Zeit für mich, ich
möchte gerne meinen neuen Patienten
vorstellen.
Okay.
Der
52-jährige
Patientin
Herr Halmut Braun, sterzt sich
heute bei uns aufgrund
von der
Verstichung der
Erbrechung
und
Erschöpfung
vor.
Der Patient
berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen
langsam
auch getreten sein
und
manchmal
die
Dyspene begleitet
sein.
Also
hat er wegen der Schmerzen Dyspene
oder wie, kann ich das verstehen jetzt?
Ja, also wenn
er sich bewegt
Treppe hochsteigt
und laufen
er
erkennt, dass er ein bisschen
Atemnot haben.
Ah, okay, also hat Belastungsdyspene
zu tun, oder?
Genau, okay.
Die
Frage nach
Sortbrinnen
und Gewichtveränderungen
wurde verneint.
Der Patient
erwähnt,
dass er
vor einem Monat
mein Arzt gewesen
um
seine
Blutverdünne
einstellen
und
Was hat er,
welche Blutverdünne hat er eingestellt?
Elikus, nehm' er
100 Milligramm.
Aber das muss man nicht einstellen, oder?
Das nimmt er,
muss man das einstellen, Elikus?
Also, ja,
vielleicht nehm' er
etwas anderes,
aber in letzter Zeit
war er
neugeschrieben.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Also er nimmt Elikus ein, ja?
Warum nimmt er Elikus ein?
War er vor
einem Jahr
ein Tifa of Tea
gehabt aber, ja?
Okay, vor einem Jahr.
Deswegen nimmt er immer noch Elikus, jetzt nach einem Jahr?
Ja.
Nicht vor einem Jahr, vor 3 Monaten.
Ah, okay, aufküchter ich.
Gut.
Der Patientin
sagte,
dass er
die
vegetative Anemise
ist unauffällig bis auf
Insomnia, Inaptants
und
Melana.
Ja.
An vorallem
leide er
an
richtenseitige Kineatros.
Es ist
Gornastros, ja?
Ja.
Seit 5 Jahren
Arteriellehipatroni
und wie gesagt vor 3 Monaten
Tifa of Tea
ist bei den Patienten bekannt.
Okay.
Das ist der Patientin, der
hat es
festgestellt.
Der Patientin
in Besuch auf Medikation
nehmt der Patient
ein
Dicklofenac
überprofen
gegen
diese Knieschmerzen
und
gegen Arteriellehipatroni
kann dieser Art am 16 Milligramm
für Tifa of Tea
der Lucas 5 Milligramm
täglich 2 Mal.
Hat er viel Dicklofenac eingenommen
oder wie?
Er hat erwähnt, dass er in der Leste
seit ein bisschen viel genommen.
Okay.
Der Patient
wurde 3
Mal
nie operiert.
Er
sei vollständig geämpft.
Gegen Corona
hat er auch 3 Mal.
Also
vor 3 Monaten
hat er
eine Reise
in
Togo gemacht
in der Aufbieter.
Okay.
Teilern
den Entschuldigung nicht Togo,
Teilern.
Okay.
Also
als Familienanwesen
gibt
der Folgendes
sein
Eltern
seien gestorben.
Vater
in Folge
Verkehrunfall
als sehr
jung
als
Vollenkerer Zeit
und
seine Mutter
aufgrund
Apopleks gestorben.
Er habe keine
Geschwister.
Er sei geschieden,
habe keine Kinder
und lebe allein.
Er
sei
selbstständig
als von Beruf.
Also
Autoverkaufer
und
er
sei Raucher
seit 25 Jahren
täglich Sehmenzigarette
das entspricht
3,5
Fixingjahr, aber
er hat
eine Weile
hausiert
so rauchen
er
trinkt
täglich ein, 2 Bier
und manchmal
noch ein Ende mehr.
Er
habe keine Bescheid
Drogenkonsum gegeben.
Er gebe keine Bescheid
der
Drogenkonsum.
Gebt er keine Auskunft darüber,
meinen Sie?
Gebt er keine Auskunft
über Drogenkonsum?
Bescheid geben
sagt man nicht, man sagt Auskunft.
Hat er die Auskunft
verweigert
über Drogenkonsum?
Kann man auch so sagen,
er wollte nicht
verraten,
dass er
Drogenkonsum
wollte nicht darüber sprechen.
Okay, gut.
Die anerlässlichen Angaben
deuten am ehesten auf
Ober-
Gastrointestinal-Belutung
auf
Pferanzialdiagnosenkommen
Magenkachsnom
Osofagus varissen
Blutung
Pryptik
Urpus
vielleicht
ja, das ist
ein
ja, das war es.
Um
den Verdach
auf
Gastrointestinal-Belutung
bestätigen
so bestätigen
und die Differenzialdiagnosen
aufzuschließen
würde ich den Patienten
so als
körperliche Untersuchungen
danach
Diagnostik durchführen
dann
Apparativdiagnostik durchführen
Was für eine
Apparativdiagnostik?
Apparativdiagnostik
würde ich den Patienten
so als
eine 2 Ebene
Abdomen
und
Torax-Rötgern aufnehmen.
Warum?
Also eine Perforation
auszuschließen
und eine
nur mit Torax oder andere
Strukturen
Okay
Sonst gar nichts
Apparativdiagnostik?
Doch, ich würde gerne
danach
eine Stronographie
im Bauchbereich
durchführen
danach
gleich auch Torax
Ultraschall
durchführen
am Ende
würde ich
wenn ein
gastrointestinal Blutung
bestätigen
oder eine Verdacht auf
die Ergebnisse
Labor
und 3x Ergebnisse
eine
gastrointestinal Blutung
erscheinen
würde ich den Patienten
durchführen
Woran machen Sie das
fest?
An welchem Blutwert
gibt es ein Blutwert für Oberkranker?
Blutwert
gibt es einen O-Gip-Wert
O-G-I-B-Wert
den Sie im Labor bestimmen können
Also wenn
der Blutungszeichnend gibt
zum Beispiel an EMI
das ist ein
Stuhlgrobe
wenn wir
Blutung
feststellen
Edigen kann man auch
Blutung
Es ist 2040
Was machen Sie
wann machen Sie Endoskopie
machen Sie heute Abend noch
die Gastroskopie?
Ja
Wir können das heute
Wir haben so Möglichkeiten
Ja, müssen Sie mich dann rufen
ich komme dann von zu Hause zu
Endoskopie oder wie
Oberarzt Hintergrund
Wenn es
nötig ist
Ist es nötig oder ist nicht nötig
sagen Sie mir
Sie müssen den Oberarzt rufen, Gastronologen
rufen Sie oder rufen Sie nicht jetzt
Also, ich bin der Klinik
dann klinik ein bisschen
Sie sagen Klinik
Was würden Sie machen heute noch
wenn es eine
Hypotone gibt
da gibt es eine Schocktape
dann
wenn wir nicht eine
durchwarten
Ich bin von 7,5
Was machen Sie mit dem Mann
Wie ist der Blutdruck?
Blutdruck ist
110, 180, 170
ist normal
wenn ich gerade mache
Wenn wir
ein bisschen morgen warten
natürlich auch
sehr
niedriger Wart
7 hemoglobin
wir müssen die Transfission
anfangen
Ich denke auf jeden Fall
eine gastronologische
Konzül
machen
und durch die Möglichkeit
eine Gastroskopie durchführen
Er muss entscheiden
Er ist
Dienstarzt und er muss überlegen
ob er den gastronologischen Hintergrund rufen muss
oder nicht
Er muss durch eine wie möglich rufen
Das ist nicht richtig
Na warum?
Weil
Dann schimpft er, wenn der Oberarzt kommt
dann kommt und sagt er
Sie Idiot, warum haben Sie mich gerufen
Ja
Weil die Obergastronatestinal
Blutung 98%
ohne
Behandlung
Therapie
oder kann man so sagen
Also was Sie machen sollten
als Kompromiss
Was würde ich machen
bei so einem Befund
wo Sie nicht ganz sicher sind
dann rufen Sie den Hintergrund an
Ich würde den bis morgen aufschieben
mit Enyscopie
aber ich wollte nochmal Ihre Meinung hören
Was denken Sie?
Er sagt okay, sehe ich aus oder ist gut
Er sagt ne ne ne, dann soll er kommen
dann haben Sie kein Problem damit
Also ein HP von 7,5
es kann sein, dass gestern 13 war heute abgefahren
dann ist es ein Notfall
dann muss man vielleicht doch überlegen
aber was bei dem Patienten auch sein kann
der hat ja 1-2 Wochen Probleme
dass er einen langsamen Blutverlust hat
und die Epidemolation ist er langsam jeden Tag verliert
und dann kann man das auch aufschieben
elektrisch auf den nächsten Tag
sehe ich auch so
Aber heute
einmal
Hermatimesis
erst mal aufgezeichnet
nicht Hermatimesis, das war
Hermatin erbrechen
nicht, warum?
Hermatina erbrochen, aber kein Blut
kein Blut, aber
kein frisches Blut
aber Hermatokäsia nicht
Hermatimesis
Hermatimesis ist nicht Blut
und Dunkel
Hermatimesis ist Blut erbrechen
ja Blut erbrechen
Hermatin erbrechen
ist eine Sonderform von Hermatimesis
vielleicht bezeichnen wir nicht als Hermatimesis
Hermatimesis ist in der Regel so, dass das dann
frisches Blut oder Blut-Co-Agel zu sehen sind
Hermatokäsia
Was bedeutet das? Hermatokäsia
Hermatoshitsi
Das ist sozusagen Blut
im Stuhl
Also Hermatin erbrechen
Also Kaffeesatz erbrechen hat auch jemand
eingeschrieben in den Chat
Also wenn der frisches Blut
erbricht
dann wäre es nochmal eine andere Situation
sehe ich aus, dann würde ich eher
zeitnah diese Endoskopie machen
bei Hermatin
erbrechen kann man überlegen
abhängig von den Vitalparametern
Laborwerten, klinischer Zustand
und dann werden wir das auch überlegen
ob man das dann elektiv am nächsten Tag macht
Ja
aber wie gesagt, es kann sein
dass ein Prüfer das nicht so sieht
deswegen würde ich empfehlen
dass man da ein Kompromiss macht
zu sagen, okay ich würde den
Hintergrunddienst
den Oberarztdienst informieren
und besprechen
ob wir die
Endoskopie akut
oder elektiv am nächsten Tag machen sollen
Ja, das ist vielleicht ein Kompromiss
weil
kann sein, dass der Prüfer
den Fall so geplant hat, dass das als
Notfall gemacht werden will
wenn sie dann sagen, nächste Tag
dann lässt sie sie durchfallen
weil er hat im Kopf das Notfall muss sein
oder der Prüfer ist so
dass er sagt, man kann am nächsten Tag machen
wenn sie dann sagen, es muss heute gemacht werden
dann sagt er, ja, muss nicht alles sein
deswegen vielleicht so in beide Richtungen
Kompromiss-Bösung
Gut, das wäre vielleicht
eine Information, die wichtig ist
Ja, sonst
Therapie genau
haben sie gesagt, Endoskopie
Diagnostik haben wir jetzt abgeschlossen
also mit dem Röntgen-Torax
und dem Röntgen-Abdomen
hätte ich nicht unbedingt gemacht
es sei denn der Bauch ist akut
irgendwie, also wenn der Bauch ist akut
wäre klinisch, dann würde ich das machen
wenn der Bauch weich ist, muss ich ehrlich sagen
würde ich nicht primär ein
Röntgenbild veranlassen
Aber Schrocken denken anders
ich weiß, ja
Aber ich denke erstmal
ein EKG-Schreiben
haben
sagen
weil
52 Jahre, viele Risikofaktoren
und
abendsabend 4 Milligramm
TVT
Rauchen
familiär, annemnes
Risikofaktoren gibt
ihre Mutter
deswegen
erstmal EKG schreiben
Was denken Sie?
Ja, also das wird sowieso immer gemacht
als Routine, wissen Sie
also wie Teilparameter EKG machen wir
bei jedem Patienten deswegen
also ich würde jetzt aber nicht so sehr drauf drängen
dass jetzt unbedingt in Richtung Herzinfarktabklärung laufen
also
klinisch ist der jetzt nicht so für mich auffällig
aber
das ist auch ein Problem
dass man bei Aufnahme
mit Teilparameter auch immer ein EKG schreibt
bei Patienten
das würde ich immer machen
gut
Labor haben wir gesagt
Ultraschall kann man machen
aber wenn der Bauch nicht akut ist
weich ist
kann man auch überlegen ob man das
später macht
verkehrt es nicht
wichtig ist dann die Endoskopie
wenn der Patient am nächsten Tag
also er bleibt da der Patient
am nächsten Tag hat er keinen Erbrechen mehr
Hemoglobin ist dann auch
stabil
würden Sie trotzdem endoskopieren oder nicht
den Patienten wenn er
keine Klinik merkt am nächsten Tag
dass Sie den Patienten
endoskopieren
muss das heute immer machen
gut
Differenzialdiagnose haben Sie ja genannt
verschieden, also angefangen
von Magenkatinom
bis hin zu Ulkos
bzw. Gastritis gibt es ja auch
Patienten die viel Alkohol trinken
und Dichlorfenacne gibt es ja auch erosive
Gastritis die dann Blutung machen kann
hemoragisch
erosive Gastritis zum Beispiel
kann sein
gut
okay aber
was Sie auch noch vielleicht beachten
müssten, das ist aber jetzt aber zurück
weil Sie haben ja diese Diagnose
dass Sie noch in dessen Erblutung im Kopf gehabt haben
bei einem Patienten bei einer Mesegespräch
und da müssen Sie halt immer, was Sie jetzt
beim Oberarzt gesagt haben
praktisch diese Schockindex und so weiter
würde ich immer versuchen im Gespräch vorher zu klären
wie ist der Puls, haben Sie Puls gemessen
oder
Fragen, Sie sind zu schwach, haben Sie Blutdruck
gemessen zu Hause
oder wenn er sagt, ich weiß nicht, ich habe mich gemessen
keine Ahnung, dann würde ich lieber mal ganz kurz unterbrechen
sagen, dann warten Sie ganz kurz mal
wir bestimmen gerade Ihre Vitalparameter
und dann machen wir
vielleicht dann direkt dann weiter
wenn die Werte einigermaßen stabil sind
dann das sind Sie auf der sicheren Seite
ja, man kann auch kein Prüfer sagen
Sie haben da einen Notfall übersehen
zum Beispiel
das habe ich auch bemerkt aber
ich habe
weswegen gefragt
haben Sie Schufe und Gefühle, Sie haben
gut gesagt deswegen
habe ich weitergemacht
bei dem Patienten war ich kritisch, sehe ich auch so
aber es gibt ja so
Prüfer, die wollen ja so
fallen stellen
dann kann man das machen
gut, gibt es etwas im Chat
was wir übersehen haben, ich ruf gerade mal den Chat aus
Antikokulation, Kastropie
ja, die Gitarre-Tageversung ist immer wichtig
weil wenn ein Patient sagt, schwarzer Stuhl
kann vieles bedeuten
deswegen immer
würde ich machen, das gehört zu Aufnahme
darüber habe ich mir gesprochen
also
wir führen Sie diese
törpallische Untersuchung
das haben wir nicht besprochen
ich habe Sie im Chat gelesen deswegen
Oremia
HG, weiß nicht was damit gemeint ist
also dann kommen wir zur Therapie
was geben Sie im Transfusion, wenn der
von Herrn Moklubin her sehr elitrig ist
und auch Kreisdorf instabil ist ja
Transfusion
PPE Infusion würde ich auch immer machen
wenn es im Krankenhaus bleibt ja
wenn es nach Hause geht kann man auch PPE Tabletten geben
Nahrungskarenz bis Zendeskopie
ist auch gut
und Kaffeesatzartig
das war wegen der HMAT E-Messis
glaube ich gewesen
oder dieser
anderen Frage, ok, dann haben wir die
Sachen im Chat auch besprochen
sonstige Kommentare
oder Fragen
war eigentlich ziemlich komplett
glaube ich
unsere Kollegen
weren´t
am Besten
ist
basically
Kollegen hab gesagt
Üblichkeit
Erbiration
und so weiter
ich hab die Frage bis dann
die Formulerünke
Können Sie machen?
Also vom Patienten, bei der Vorstellung beim Oberarzt, meinst du?
Ja, vorstellend.
Ja, ich hätte auch gesagt, es ist ein Patient, der mit Übelkeit und heute einmaligem Kaffeesatzärtigen
Erbrechen sich vorgestellt hat und an einem Nestig seit ein bis zwei Wochen Oberbauchmagenbeschwerden
angibt, außerdem eine körperliche Schwäche beklagt, auch Belastungsdüstpneuer und nachdem
wir gefragt haben auch berichtet, dass er Teerstuhl abgesetzt hat, mehrfach.
Das wäre so meine wichtigste Zusammenfassung der Akkulbeschwerden vom Patienten.
Dankeschön.
Okay, dann war aber eine gute, kompakte Vorstellung.
Doktor, alle herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Mit Brille habe ich es nicht erkannt, ohne Brille.
Machen Sie Brille ab.
Das kennen wir uns natürlich.
Ich habe mit Brille nicht erkannt.